When I tried it, I felt better than I ever had so... I just kept on doing it
Why?
I don't know. I thought we were closer than most fathers and sons. This isn't us.
This is not who we are-
...Both of you, stop
There are moments that I look at him and I wonder who he is
How's that boy David? I'm not giving up now. Never
You always gotta be controlling everything-
It doesn't make any sense.
You're controlling me right now!
Let us help you-
I don't want your help don't you understand that?
I had such grand plans
You'd graduate from college, do something amazing. And now I just want you to not die
Who are you Nick?
This is me, Dad. Here. This is who I am
If you could take all the words in the language it's still indescribable how much I love you. I love you more than everything
I'm really sorry, Dad
It's hard as hell to get sober
But I love my family
I want them to be proud of me
I understand how scared you are. It'll pass though. It always does
Nic, what you have is extraordinary
And you're gonna get it back. You're gonna find it again